[Applaudissements]
un
jour j'ai quitté mon village pour la
ville et en arrivant j'ai cru qu'une
main de géant venait de frapper mon
visage la vie de Dan est à mes yeux
comme un balai
exceptionnel réglé par les forces du
ciel animé par le feu de dieu feu de
dieu la terre semblait jaillir les
accords d'une
symphonie composé de champ et de bruit
de cris de larmes et de
rire et des feux rouges jaunes et verts
semblait vouloir
réglementer la marche plus ou moins
pressée de tout un
monde
[Applaudissements]
parolé
des uneformme Bâ la mesure avec un bâton
blanc canalisant le grand trafic de
cette masse en mouvement ce à bouche
appelé
métropolitain sans app ou
rejetéimmense flot humain je pensais
attention attention attention
la ville est d'une étrange
dame dont le cœur a le goût du drame
elle est sans cœur elle est sans âme
elle est comme un gouffreux
son pourtant j'étais émerveillé de ce
que j'avais
découvert cœur battant les yeux grands
ouverts avec l'impression de rêver de
rêver sans savoir que j'étais tombé dans
le couffre des illusions
entraîné dans un tourbillon
[Musique]
unensé dans la foule
inissante dans la foule
puissante une
fille avec un teint de plâtre
[Musique]
m toi qui portes en ton
cœur les EAU fortes
d'ailleurs sans regret
entre dans mon
a moi dans la
tor ce que
eu comme un
gosse
perdu croyant que
[Musique]
c'était la
Providence je l'ai
suivi tout le
jour mais dans ma nuit
d'amour
elle la rie
elle a rie
elle
[Musique]
a
attention
[Musique]
la
vi tu es
TR dans le cœur à le C du drame
elle est sans cœur
elle est sans
âme
elle a volé nos
[Musique]
illusions à Dieu ma vie Mons cœur cruel
faux paradis pour
malheureux qui me jetait la pvre au yeux
pour m'empêcher de voir le ciel voir le
ciel et dans le froid du petit jour tu
vois je par
dabuser avec
l'espoir de
retrouver ma
maison mon
soleil mes
amis
mes
[Musique]
amours